my first job out of college was working
at a group home for at-risk teenagers I
mean it was the craziest thing that I've
ever done and seeing firsthand the
effects of bad parenting I was forced to
think about questions that I've never
thought about before and a lot of those
questions stuck with me all the way
through my my time at film school my
caesars project was a short film called
short term 12 the film premiered at
sundance and we ended up winning the
jury prize there that was the first time
that I realized how universal this story
is and I knew there was just so much
more to tell about this world so it
started the long process of trying to
write the future screenplay and then
beginning of 2010 I submitted a draft to
the nickel fellowship I submitted and I
didn't think anything of it and then I
got that first email that we got into
the quarterfinals and then I just kept
going until finally I got the call I was
trying to say something but like nothing
was coming out of my mouth and I can't
even describe what it feels like to have
any kind of nod from the Academy it just
feels like a warm hug
I mean there's so many best parts of the
nickel experience it's not just winning
it it's also this continuing support and
love from from a community that is so
open and really does feel like a family
yeah I met some of my best friends
through the nickel fellowship so it's in
a weird way I'd like to thank the
academy for my friends the year that I
won the fellowship Michael Arndt gave
the speech of that night and it was
hands down the best speech I've ever
heard in my life the words that were
coming out of his mouth were were rooted
in humility and I think the the best
piece of advice that I absorbed from who
he is is to always have a a grateful and
thankful attitude toward any of this I
mean it's crazy that we're able to
continue to tell stories and play
make-believe for a living you know
wonderful